I thought I thought you'd break the ice
by by asking Steve to share with you the
story of his college degree which he
just recounted to me and what was
important to me and my parents told me
you know they went to college and what
college they went to Wow and since I was
a good student you know of course
college is always part of your plans in
between college years I would take off
years to work to earn money for my next
college year one of those years I took
off I get got jobs with the greatest
companies you look Packard and then we
did all these projects and started Apple
Computer and it was ten years but I
finally went back I had an airplane
crash and I called up Steve Jobs and I
said I'm going back to college get my
degree and I went back under a fake name
to Berg to Berkeley I'm sorry but you
know if you got three years down you
might as well go back to the same school
and yeah so the name was rocky racoon
Clark and that's what it says on my
diploma and it was kind of neat being
sort of an anonymous little 19 year old
almost they thought and rocky they
called me up yeah love that name I tell
you until your picture appeared on the
front of the last day of fine and
that'll pretty much blow it for you I
made it I made it you made that pretty
anonymously the thing that intrigues me
as a business school professor is we
have a lot of students coming through
who who aspire to entrepreneurial
careers and and one of the challenges is
that many of them don't have technology
backgrounds right they they would love
to be involved in in in tech startups
but aren't the technologists and so I'm
interested in kind of that that
interface the interface between the
business person on the team and the
technology person on the team and so I
wanted to ask you as you know the
consummate technology guy I mean someone
who-who loved loved to engineer and who
who loved the beauty of getting it
exactly right and and so on from the
technologist perspective is is there
value in having a partner on the on the
business side so I mean you know it's a
absolutely critical um as a matter of
fact I totally admire the business
people I would not want to be one
because I have just
internal passions philosophies beliefs I
I don't want to be political and direct
other people and step on toes and run
companies so I decided I'd just be an
engineer in the lab hooking up wires and
doing that for for all my life pretty
much but the most important thing that
made Apple successful compared to a lot
of other startups at the time was we had
the right people in the right places
high quality you know basically mostly
business people that knew how to
organize the the business what kind of
which sort of disciplines we needed
covered with with people and what kind
of people we needed what their roles
would be right so thankfully Steve and I
would our young 20s you know and we had
no business experience no business
schooling and no money so we really had
a little bit of fortunate guidance from
outside people who had been successful
what would you say to someone on the
young person on the business side trying
to to find technologists to work with I
mean is there
default yeah one thing is well even a
businessman just looking you know you're
not you're not gonna be too successful
unless it's in your heart your passion
you want to be the sort of person that
can create companies that develop
products or services and then takes it
to another level and another level if
that's not your dream in life you're
just sort of here because it's a holding
place you wound up in that's probably
not where you're gonna wind up and all
of us inside have little passions of
certain direction something we might
want to do for automobiles or energy or
homes or things at our life and usually
even as a business person in the end
that you're gonna go in that direction
when you get the chance how do you
recognize though good engineering talent
you know there's about one out of ten
engineers that's sort of an artist
that's how well what I found looking
around the engineers at Apple you know
and I was one of them and the artist
just every little piece of code has to
be so perfect
they're almost kind of perfectionist and
they're proud of what they did is better
than almost anybody else would do then
the masses would do and you got to find
somebody who's just so caring about say
you're starting a company you know maybe
it's working on some new battery
technology somebody who just absolutely
talks and talks and talks and has all
these ideas and it's not about this
technology and that might play out and
they might not even have experience
exactly in batteries but they're good at
taking pieces of chemistry and physics
and whatever and putting it together and
creating things you've just got to find
that person they're hard to find best if
the if the engineers that you work with
you're starting a new company you're
small it's best if you can find an
engineer that can cover a lot of the
disciplines and not divide it down into
one guy will do this design one guy will
draw it on paper another guy will write
the manual another person will will
actually design it another person will
build it another person will test it you
just if you can't get that down to one
person it's very difficult in a start-up
situation yeah you have to really do
what we're after which is you know kind
of doing new things that haven't been
done before do you think that the the
technical side is becoming less
important or more important its and so
you know if you think about the consumer
Internet you think about social
networking and a lot of those are
business ideas where the technology side
is not the gating factor right and it's
just it's not that hard and so is that
is that a trend that we're gonna see or
or is technology going to be yeah I
think new technologies are enablers for
some of the ideas that sit around and
just four years even or something we
could possibly do and sometimes
technology is a real key to that
especially in the hardware rina a lot of
today's you know world is our creative
what we used to create we hooked things
together and they perform some tasks and
nowadays it's mostly software it's
mostly an internet related and and so
it's hard to say what technology
invention that comes from people who
study atoms and crystalline structures
and the physics involved and create new
materials with new properties less of
that although there are different
categories what if you were going to be
wanted to build certain kind of robotics
a robot that could wash a car or wash
dishes what do you want to build up you
know a spacecraft first you know send
some that Rover to the moon well yeah so
you can wind up in categories where oh
yes somebody who totally understands the
science up to date is more important a
lot of the computer software people when
the internet started weren't really
professional you know and to this day I
think that's probably true they can just
sort of hack away and get something to
work on the screen the right way and
leave hundreds of just outright bugs
flaws contradictions to the specs in the
in the actual code that they created
it's a very difficult world to actually
even create websites nowadays on your
own from scratch it's not like like it
once was where one person can kind of
sit down and create something new and
great it's very innovative with the
constraints of the machine
we're so great in terms of memory and
other attributes that you really yeah
everything had yeah now the hardware
world has gone through such a huge
evolution of new products new products
better products faster products you know
unbelievable products that um you know
and we've gotten pretty much to one of
those plateaus where we're just sort of
adding the incremental improvements that
you'd expect there are some new
technologies on the forefront you know
you might speed processors ten times a
hundred times a thousand times by
switching light instead of electrons but
but pretty much you know we're at sort
of a stable point where hardware changes
aren't influencing the changes in our
life and how we use computers yeah you
know it's it's more in the software area
so you know there's the technical aspect
in some some parts of the technical
aspect yes have become less however
every company you know that runs
factories and has manufacturing this and
all does get involved in a lot of
especially robotics type work and that
involves some of the the hardware the
engineering the circuit knowing how much
voltage and current is flowing in the in
the wires so we we talk and think a lot
about entrepreneurship here and if we go
back to kind of the early days of Apple
my understanding is you know I mean you
weren't looking for a start-up you were
you you know you weren't that interested
even in in leaving a great engineering
job at HP I myself but you personally
yeah I had a very difficult time but you
know when we first started we weren't
starting a computer company we were
starting company to build a little board
to sell for 40 bucks a blank board and
didn't know if we'd get our money back
but you know just as friends we'd have
our little tight company for once in our
lives and that's that's just that's a
good enough reason now Steve always had
this Drive he always wanted to be one of
the great people in the of this vision
of making companies of having companies
and if you can get some money from a
company you can build more products and
make more money and he always had the
drive in the focus and if you don't have
a goal that's driving your life you know
you're not gonna get there me I just
wanted to build the best computers
possible so we were just like it was
just like an ideal team because what I
could do he couldn't do and vice versa
yeah and for you looking back how much
pride do you have
in the in the formation and growth of
Apple Computer as a company versus what
you know versus your contributions to
the PC industry which could have been
done through other avenues and it could
have ended up in Commodore if they'd had
more sense or in Atari if they if they
had what would you have had as much
satisfaction if it had gone that route I
don't like to think back and think what
if we had done different things in the
company and it had gone in different
paths and what wound up either greater
or worse than it is today
the company's always been it's very
healthy in terms of profits and cash
flow and survivability have been very
proud of that the company's always had a
reputation for new interesting things
pursuing the state-of-the-art and taking
the people in different directions than
the rest of the world's going so I'm
extremely pleased about where the
company is going today the current
products reflect our early not our
values so much as what we started
getting known for and when you do
something and you're an engineer you're
a businessman you put something into a
product and all of a sudden it has
success you start for the rest of your
life that is this that's a memory you
have of something that was successful in
your business and you're gonna keep
going on long those lines so we were
lucky that we had a few very innovative
jump ahead of the world successes early
on and that drives our passion as to
what is the right way to run a business
from then on you know and even little
experiences like working to have a
different kind of power supply so you
don't need a fan for years and years
you'll say let's keep the fans out of
computers they get in people's ways but
it's really like a lot of these little
early experiences really drives the
company to its current state and we got
a reputation for having easier to use
computers so we think of ourselves that
way the world thinks of ourselves that
way and that drives us into thinking
it's like if you know yourself inside I
am this is one thing I'm good at in
school my teacher praised me at math I'm
a man you'll go in that direction you
know that it's like a positive feedback
then you'll work harder to be what you
know you're already good at so if the
company has some some early successes
and boundaries don't keep trying to go
in that you know the culture will stay
for sometimes decades you know and Apple
is very much them very much the early
products Apple you see in today's not
exactly you could draw a lot of
distinctions but yeah how much of of
where the industry ended up going
did you have any inkling about in the in
there oh we had no inkling we talked
about what what these computers we were
going to build at first might do and you
know even after we got through the point
of not building a board but building
some little hobby computers and then
building a real computer as a product
and raising the money that was when we
were at a real company we talked about
how it might influence people's lives
and be used and we thought of things
that were so different than what came to
be I mean yes you do balance your
checkbook on it so we had that one hey
eventually that would happen and you
might keep your recipes on a computer
but they just the sorts of things that
computer can do like hundreds of
thousands of things and we just couldn't
be familiar with all those things and
uses and needs and applications it's
very difficult to look ahead and say in
this future year we're gonna have this
much memory and this much hard disk and
that will make a whole another thing
possible
you really don't know it's when
engineers get in the lab and start
trying to make those things you find out
which ones do work out well enough to
put into products and you do find out
which ones get accepted by the populace
this is the way I want to go you know
and and and there's a lot of fickleness
you know people will sometimes will
change their direction you know sort of
in big masses like the whole mass of
computer users will all start going a
new way when something appears and in a
short period one we in a one year almost
everybody will be on the new thing face
face face you know whatever it is my
place you know whatever the newest do
you do you do you think that you've
you've developed some kind of sense for
figuring out where markets are going in
a way that you didn't have then or are
you still a you know throw it against
the wall and see what happened it's kind
of going oh no no I think it's very
important to to study where the markets
are and where they're gonna go the
trouble is it's not that good for the
person who has a totally new idea that
does things in a different way than ever
before it's almost like I look at my
iPhone and it's a product that did some
things that we're done but it's very
different way than other people you know
and sometimes it takes more steps
sometimes it's clumsier but maybe it has
a better feel it's just different enough
one of the things is you've got to
differentiate yourself from everybody
else that's out there that's been a
strong philosophy of Apple and you've
got to do quality and excellence I mean
people you hire in a company if you
don't have you know every one of them is
trying to be a better than almost anyone
in the world then you really you really
could do better than you're doing yeah I
think that's that's the you think and
should always be I'm gonna try to do as
well as I can also you spend a lot of
hours when you have startup companies
you know especially the executives even
the engineers you're just working you
know day and night that I mean it's a
lot of 20-hour days and you can do it
when you're young you know make
something make it something going and
then that buys you a lot of freedom to
have a lot of your own choice in the
future of the company yeah where do you
see the whole field of personal
computing going and I use that term very
broadly I mean you can encompass the
phone I feel that the computer oddly
enough it's been pretty much typing
looking at a screen for you know decades
now and I don't see that changing hugely
but I see the computer the tasks that
it's doing today are pretty much the
tasks it did 10 years ago
oddly enough and we've got any balancing
the check yes and I think of important
things in life are like food fun and
friends your necessities of life that's
business the computer is used for
business to you know to manage meetings
and calendars and and documentation and
everything and then fun is entertainment
and that would that would include games
but includes a lot more than that it
includes the internet you know looking
up and finding finding you know where
the movies are and and friends is
communication so these are the things
that computers use for and I don't
really see those categories changing
that much the things we did in our life
listening to music watching television
that we did you know even 50 years ago
really are the things that computers are
being applied to the computers become
kind of the central central item of your
life to the rest of the world though and
that just makes it so important why was
our iPod so successful in my I have an
opinion that it wasn't it was because it
was the first music device there was not
a music device it was a satellite to the
computer it treated the computer as the
heart of things and it's easier to build
a satellite just plug in and no steps
there it is so a lot of one of the one
of the big goals that one things Apple's
done very well is do the complete job do
the entire job from somebody purchases a
piece of music to it's in a system Alma
and as few steps as you can you can get
to get the music to your ear which is
what the person
wanted they didn't want a computer they
didn't want a music device they just
wanted music to their ear and we have to
build the steps you've got to make them
really efficient that's one thing apples
good at getting there you know all in
one step it's like the new Amazon Kindle
it's one device does your purchasing and
it's your device your usability it's
your content is everything you don't
have to attach to other things or even
have an instruction manual
can we talk about philanthropy for for a
minute yeah I'm not the normal
philanthropist I was a young and Apple
was very successful in I never won but I
turned down starting the company at
first I turned down the big money and I
said I don't want to get in life I want
to be an engineer hila packard for the
rest of my life and I didn't like having
it I kind of opposed it so I wanted to
start you know I started eyes good
people I don't look at here's a project
I want to invest him I would find some
people and they cared so much about a
type of project Children's Discovery
Museum or whatever and then invested in
them basically give them the money no
strings because they you'll do the best
job and and I enjoy I enjoy that kind of
work that enjoy serving on nonprofit
boards when I have time okay I'm gonna
open it up in a second but I can't
resist asking you about about kids
because we have kids that are roughly
the roughly the same age I have true
that I've graduated and once and in high
school so my youngest is younger than
your youngest but not that far apart so
they've grown up with an unusual dad to
say the least how how do you think about
I know I've I've heard you saying I've
actually read you say you don't believe
in imposing your your values on your
kids but you must have kind of
aspirations for the values that they
would that they would have and hold the
air right and what about like my own
father I looked at my children and don't
want to say this is why this is the
guide you should have this where you
should go in life pretty much let them
go out to the world have their friends
their encounters their school's their
movies they watch and where they get an
interest want to go some way help them
get there give give them extra you know
resources facility instruction comments
of your own feelings about it praise
whatever yeah and that's been raised to
test why I hide my pretty much my
position in the world I hide it from the
kids it's my
I can and they grew up pretty much never
being exposed to things like my
presentations to large crowds that sort
of thing oh gosh um some of the play
everybody get in on the ground floor a
greatest invention well nobody will ever
be able to build a robot that can make a
cup of coffee that I'm sure of
you'd have to do a lot of thinking to
come up with why but the artificial
intelligence will never get that far
along we won't build robots that work
and learn the way people do but um I
don't know recently just they're coming
up with a lot of materials for flexible
displays that are you know the glowing
organic LED ones and I thought if you
could make that misshape of a globe like
the world the earth that's sort of the
human aspect of the earth and you could
just sort of tap in places to zoom-in
Goods displaying Google Earth display
the entire Google Earth and tap in and
check out the data on you know volcanoes
and cams around the world they'd show up
as blue dots one just once you've zoomed
in far enough and and I don't know that
sort of thing just you know human
common-sense things and there's a few
technology products I'm working with but
I'm with companies I don't want to talk
about that
Oh God we were best friends for eight
years so what do you mean that was the
exact right thing to do um I didn't see
any no no challenges at all I made a
decision in my own mind that I don't
know everything and I'm not gonna try to
over to make decisions for people that
we hired that have done marketing for 10
years or 20 years why should I tell them
I have a better idea you know I saw I
will stay in my engineering and do that
very very well my part of the the whole
company I did hardware and the software
so I was a very versatile engineer but
yeah we know it was great and it was
great to watch things we defined our
roles when we started Apple and pretty
much we had one money guy that had
business success and he had an equal
ownership to Steve Jobs and myself you
never hear about him because he didn't
come from nothing he's not that good of
that good of a newspaper story but
pretty much he ran the marketing which
he had done before at Intel and he also
had us hire a week we hired a president
an Operations minded guy who looks at
the various things that you have to get
done to be successful with this product
and make sure everybody's doing the jobs
that have to get done so you don't wind
up ever saying oh we're missing one
thing
and Steve Jobs his role was to find this
he would just participate in every every
aspect of the company learning to be an
executive in every category and might
not be engineering so we had a real good
understanding right from the start of
how we would organize and and get this
thing going we had to be very versatile
though the market went in different
directions than we had surmised and when
it went in those other directions thank
God it was a new industry made it very
easy for us to switch over easily and
start pursuing the directions it was
going
graduated from Lourdes the actual easy
going from a board to a PC well no no
the first suggestion was Steve Jobs said
why don't we
I was already given away the computer I
designed it became the Apple one I was
giving it away no copyright notices
design schematics I was helping people
build them at a club where we had about
twice as this member number of people
would meet regularly and they just
wanted their own computer in life Steve
came along said let's make the PC board
to save them time we'll make it for 20
bucks itself for 40 and we came up when
we started to cut me but I said first of
all I'm an engineer hewlett-packard for
life and I'm gonna make sure I'm gonna
get in trouble with them so I went to
Yale at Packard and proposed they build
a computer a little computer of your own
that could run a programming language
and talk to your TV set and they turned
me down for some good hewlett-packard
reasons but but that's the first time a
first of five times they turned me down
then when Steve Jobs called one day and
said guess what I got an order for
$50,000 my salary was 24,000 as an
engineer at Hewlett Packard $50,000
scared me it was such a big number so I
went back through Gila Packard's legal
department because I wasn't gonna get in
trouble with my own company I mean my
sense of ethics you know and any
promises to them came first and Hewlett
Packard turned me down again and they
turned me down again and again so we we
just went out and started on their own
how do you start it with no money how do
you build 500 computers that you're
gonna sell for 50,000 bucks 100
computers how do you build them with no
money we got the parts on 30 days credit
and then we built them kind of in 10
days they got built at a company
actually we just we just drove him from
the company to the garage we tested them
plugged them in test him out put him in
a white box and we drove him to the
store and got paid cash so we have 30
days credit we got paid cash we ran for
like half a year that way maybe a year
we sold a couple couple hundred a couple
hundred computers sold about 150 of them
and and we didn't have that much of
money we'd built up a bank account of
about $10,000 and that was when we had
to raise big money because now we had
the computer that we could sell
thousands of the Apple to I wouldn't
just ask a fellow up because HP today is
a completely different company but the
HP at the time had a reputation for
recognizing internal technology and
seizing upon it and I mean the entire
printer company HP was so different it
was an engineering company founded by
engineers interns through the management
we engineers at the bottom of the org
chart
come up with the ideas that would take
our division into its next products the
ideas didn't come from only above the
the communication was all
multi-directional but we were good at
marketing because we were building tools
that engineers used in those days we
built the scientific calculator Sheila
Packard bill oscilloscope Sheila Packard
bill signal generators they don't need
the test equipment that engineers like
themselves used so it wasn't too hard to
surmise what wouldn't my customer want
but sir then why did they miss this so
that's the interesting question cuz they
they were they missus they started their
own project in this area that eventually
and wouldn't let me on the project I
said I'll do anything even though I had
just written a basic by myself and they
had five people assigned to write a
basic and they had the dynamic they had
tag name remember they had all the parts
that I had put in the Apple - they had
it there a little timing video screen
and I had done so much more in a better
project but they wouldn't let me on that
one hmm fascinating yeah I might have
been might have been jealousy and yeah
you know it might have been they want me
to say in calculators
I didn't understand that question
I was on the Macintosh team I was
designing hardware for the Macintosh
band plane crash and I had a memory
problem yet for five weeks I had amnesia
type of amnesia and when I came out of
the amnesia I called Stephen said I'm
gonna go back to school now Apple was
large enough with a lot of engineers and
able to run and get the projects
designed and built introduced to the
marketplace without one key engineer
being there and and I you know what I
when I was young I just had these ideas
of who I was that I was gonna I wasn't
gonna let the apples business success
change me who I was I was gonna get my
college degree I also had a goal all my
life that I was going to teach fifth
graders and so when I got a chance I
finally went back and talked fifth
graders for eight years kept the press
away but I did it and and it was a big
part of my life teaching a lot of kids
and then older kids and teachers as well
and I did love teaching you know I
didn't I just didn't want to say I have
to fall into a new category and do
different things in life that I would
have done if there was no Apple
all right well I think I was just like a
born leader when I was young I was
always the leader in my groups of young
kids even when I was a nerd out of the
social realm in high school
my group of little techie people who
could talk electronics I was always the
leader deciding here's what we'll do and
this is that plus I was I was also a
head I was the brightest and a lot of
people wouldn't know what I was
extremely athletic then got my Bloch
sweaters and all that but I was um just
I was just not never wanted to be a
follower I thought about that
philosophically read Walden Pond wanted
to be kind of self-sufficient rely on my
own resources and just didn't want to go
along say in the same words as everyone
else and then you're just a follower you
think different thoughts that's a lot of
where it comes from and and Steve Jobs
and a lot of people the counterculture
back in those days were that way whom I
admired I was sort of I'd like to
appreciate the counterculture wasn't a
part of it but it was all you know it
was right here
Stanford it was all a palo alto area
where a lot of these ideas came from the
early ideas that that spurred the
personal computers came probably more
from this area than anywhere else I
don't know what keeps me going
I'm not too well managed my life is
sometimes very out of balance some
months I'm only home a couple of days of
the month I try I pretty much say yes to
everybody for almost anything a lot of
interesting ideas that go around and I
try to find young people that remind me
of Steve Jobs and I when we were
starting and I try to get involved with
them and help them out with their
startups their companies their
directions and I just I just I really
liked seeing that you know going back to
that era in my life it was a very
incredible era we knew we were onto
something revolutionary and when other
young people are feeling that yeah I
love being around those things not the
big huge public company realms I yeah I
pretty much avoid that much my friends
are interesting technical people working
on neat little things sometimes they're
a little bit on the hacker side but
they're the interesting people the world
they're the ones you'll see movies about
and I don't Nick the CEOs of the world
my friends that much you know not that
they're bad or anything but
it's just it's just not not my interest
as much
Oh innovation um I was lucky I was just
building the exact product uh my goal
was so fixed in my head and I was so
good at using the parts to get there
it's like you have an architecture of a
building and you're so good at using the
components to build the building and so
I never really um in all of the Apple
projects I ever worked on up until we
started even ones that I worked on after
we were very successful never once that
I have less than an a-plus project a
plus result and I just all be set down
my own ideas but I didn't have anybody
else telling me here's what you're gonna
do
I didn't describe on paper in advance I
am going to do this that that meet these
specs and this and that and I'll have it
done by a certain date never once
happened I just sit down with start
hooking wires together seeing what I got
get another idea add a little bit on to
it and it always finished every one of
them finished I was used to when I was
very very young in elementary school I
worked on long projects that were months
long with hundreds and hundreds of parts
to build computer type projects and that
sort of thing so I was used to long
projects I built my own ham radio and
that was hundreds of hours when I was in
fifth grade and you know and what so you
get used to there you can have a goal
that's way off and it's gonna be a long
time to get there and on the way you can
make little changes and improvements but
you'll but you get there and it's not
like you don't want it well the problem
that you're referring to is well an
engineer think oh my gosh what if we did
it this way now what if we did this
other way whatever and you never come to
an end point I was maybe I was lucky I
just never got to that point I think I
was so skilled I think it was my skills
at cooking chips up that were available
in those days and you didn't have a lot
of freedom of what chips you could buy
and I just saw I knew the pattern that
was right and optimally I could look at
it and say you aren't gonna do better
than this pretty probably nobody in the
world is gonna do better so I had that
going for me too I didn't want it and I
wanted to get things done more than
anything else in the world I was shy and
put in the way I communicated get
something good done as a as an
engineering project go show it to other
people and they look over and praise you
and then I had conversations and that
was really one of my big motivating
factors and so I had to get things done
that I could work and show to people and
that's what it was doing it at the
homebrew Computer Club I even wrote a
basic because Bill Gates had written a
basic and he got known by our little
club the rest of the world had no idea
who he was just the computers were hobby
kits they were for technical people only
nobody knew know about it we knew his
name I thought if I write a basic people
know my name it's like I'll get praised
for it and I was too shy never once
raised my hand and the whole you know
years of the homebrew Computer Club I
never once raised my hand to speak I was
too scared to but if I had something if
I showed something off people come talk
to me and I'd explain it given your
experiences at the EFS how do you view
open source methodology and technology
as having a transformative effect on
business industry not just software
development in terms of facilitating I'm
not an expert on open source so much and
I saw when I started the EF f it was in
the basis of civil liberties being so
important to me in my life so I and two
other people put the money in and I was
on the first board but once it got into
dealing with politicians and in
Washington DC I pulled out of it I got
off the board because I don't I don't
want to want to be in politics I just
not my thing in life open source is so
great it just says if you have ideas
you're a young single person a young
person at home at school kid maybe you
have an idea of how to extend a product
that already exists open source lets you
do that it lets you look at their
program and add in pieces of your own to
make it a little different a little more
specialized a little better and that's
you know when we came up with the Apple
2 it was the most open product in the
world we taught anybody how to write
every kind of program and plug in every
piece of hardware to adapt that computer
and make it in things we never imagined
and thousands of little companies
started up and I went over to houses of
high school kids that discovered they
could break this program and get their
keyboard to do something in music and
you know they had the place to have
their companies in the world they were
it was like tons and tons of
entrepreneurs who never knew that they'd
ever have a place in the world to start
a business had that chance
an open-source kind of kind of gives
that now for real companies making
products i'm almost every company I've
been associated with in recent years
always ops to go open-source maybe it's
just the ones I've been with and it's
just the you know it's basically when
you hire good people they generally
think that way anyway the One Laptop Per
child project of Nicholas Negroponte II
Steve Jobs offered him Apple's operating
system for it and he turned it down
because he's and I really respect him
for that he's a pure person
wanted it to be open-source you know and
and even for free wouldn't take Apple's
operating system
if you are so open or if you are so into
officers what do you think about Apple
closing the eye quality in everything
every update I don't watch the fact that
the iPhone is closed partly because I'm
a gadget guy and I'm a computer guy I
wanted to be open so I could write my
own programs on it and restricting that
I don't like but I think the iPhone I
know some engineers too and it's like it
was a little bit rush project to get
done and there's a little bit of this
insecurity when something's too new as
to how safe it would be to let people
write the programs I don't know why in
the world I can't explain to myself why
a company stops you if you know how to
of dragging a ringtone file in why would
they want to prevent that sort of thing
how is that going to damage a tMT's
network but and a lot of us were sad
that it went with AT&T but as far as the
actual operation of the iPhone I don't
have any complaints with that doing what
it's meant to be you know you can go
through this life of modifying
everything you get and being a little
changer and changing changer and after a
while when you get spoiled enough times
and people crush you and there's a new
product and all the all the work you've
done to make yours better by adding some
third-party programs to your computer
all of a sudden they don't work anymore
if you go through that enough times you
just say I'll just buy something good
and stick with it and let it work and so
you know it's an easier safer life for
all and for the better people but I
believe so much of the young technical
people I wish they have the open-source
but I mean thank you know of course they
went to work and they pretty much
cracked the iPhone to some extent and it
is programmable by those who know how
and this act and you know might act but
you know for nothing
but not that I'm a developer not that
I'm in the development since just so
that you know you get in these certain
crowds that are all tech techie people
you get in some crowds and nobody has an
iPhone I was just down at a show in LA
called eg top level brightest people
talking and walked with our large
entertainment groups nobody had an
iPhone but you go to some other places
and everybody has an iPhone you want to
pull it out and everybody let's right
away to see if you packed yours so I
just wanted to make sure I was in the
right we'd expect you expect nothing
less yeah I was sated recently with the
director and the producer of the
Olympics for NBC and at a table and they
both pulled out their iPhones showed
they were hacked the difference is in
their case you're in the early days of
Apple we were in very different roles he
was in like running the company roles
and I was in engineering and even when
we had our first little secondary office
I moved over to that to work with a
couple engineers only and we weren't
around the same places of the company so
when you hear about Steve Jobs atrocious
behavior with other people that really
you know hurts other people in ways I
never once really witnessed it I was
never around those scenes he always
treated me with respect even when I
didn't have knowledge about something
and was trying to speak on it he
wouldn't criticize me the way he is
known for criticizing other people you
know I know from firsthand reports
that's how he is and we pretty much
stayed pretty close for quite a while
and I remember even I mean even when I
wouldn't be working with him he called
me over after my plane crashed I went
back to Apple called me over to the
Macintosh building one night to show me
the the 1984 ad before it was on TV and
and Wow
I told me that the board wasn't gonna
put it on the Superbowl and I asked well
how much does it cost I thought that was
the reason so I said I'll pay half of it
if you will and I was that naive to
think that was the reason the board
wouldn't show it on the Superbowl but um
but you know over time we spent less and
less time together so it's more just
occasional contact for you know friendly
reasons he's called up very happy with
Apple's recent huge success in its
capitalization values called up
extremely just
about you know how what we started could
get you know do so well and I'd love to
see him when he's happy I saw him on
stage with Bill Gates just had that old
happy look you know and he that normally
doesn't isn't sort of person that laughs
at many jokes I had to work hard to get
him to laugh once you're in a cooling
Joe Klein I get ran the first style of
Joe Klein the first call if call phone
number get a joke first one in the Bay
Area and you'll meet a lot of people who
start companies in your life but this is
the only time ever you're gonna meet
somebody who started the first dial a
joke in a regional area in the United
States and the reason is it was hard it
was very hard to do in 1972 in the
United States it was illegal to own use
or purchase your own telephone in 1972
in the United States it was illegal to
own purchase or use an answering machine
so I had to least the one answering
machine that the phone company offered
me and it was as much as my apartment
rental okay and I and I'm a 21 year old
engineer and I'm paying my apartment
rental and then I had to pay it again
just to run a joke machine because I
believe so much in jokes wait where did
you source the jokes back in those days
my source of jokes was the popular joke
book of the time it was polish italian
joke book and the polish the Polish
American Congress incorporated
threatened me with a lawsuit for
defaming people of Polish descent like
myself and I and I said what if I change
him to Italian jokes and they said okay
because there's just before political
correctness it was very a different time
for jokes
joining tell us a joke from from from
that era from that era yeah there was on
your joke machine yeah then they like I
used to voice then they the died
drinking milk then the cow sat down but
another joke that I told it an
engineering graduate college a college
and during graduation though I was
trying to point out how people take
things a little bit too literally
without thinking I said what do you call
for Mexicans in quicksand cuatro Sinko
and it's not a joke about Hispanic
people but boy no I was told it offended
400 people in the audience
and you know the laughter is worth more
than the negatives but there's a
question in the back question you
mentioned you never thought that we
would get computers that can make a good
cup of coffee
I'm personally challenged by this even
not being a computer but then you said
you didn't see technology go in
artificial intelligence going to
replicating human actions I know the
makers of Terminator and other movies
will be sad why do you see technology
not going towards replicating human
actions I sure can't or shouldn't sure
I'll be happy to discuss that you could
walk into my house and you could
probably make a cup of coffee you know
how to walk across floors avoid
obstacles recognize what our chairs you
know how to find what probably is the
kitchen by objects that are in it you
know how to look at a machine and say
that's probably a coffee machine it's
about the right size and I'll look at it
forwards and pull some things oh this
opens here and you put something in
there and you open up drawers and find
what might fit in there and the only
reason you know to do all that stuff is
because you've been taught and you've
made coffee your whole life and gone
through years and years of experiences
that lead you up to even being able to
make a cup of coffee in my house and the
sort of thinking that's involved you'd
almost have to imagine a robot that
we're taught and somebody will say here
you show the robot here is how you do
this and it has an eye and now it goes
up it sort of knows it and knows that
there's different kinds of coffee
machines and here's the pieces that
might fit here no no it's an awful lot
that goes on in a human mind for such a
simple statement is making a cup of
coffee a simpler robot is one like the
iRobot Roomba the clear cleans your
rooms
that's a simpler concept I'd like to
build one that just goes outside and all
night long for eight hours goes up and
one square centimeter at a time washes
my car real it has an eye it has an eye
it knows when it's getting close it
doesn't do any any actions that might
damage something only soft real soft
test sure but it would finish the job in
a long time and good I can sleep and I
would kind of like that there'd be sort
of a neat piece of technology so there's
some things that robotics is really
primed for I'm waiting for the Apple two
of our robots and they make kits that I
would call the Apple two robots in Japan
but nothing's taken off yet
would you question you spoke about the
counterculture when you started out with
and also about the homebrew Computer
Club you tell us some stories about that
you feel that that's still around that
kind of very focused innovation that was
the most important thing in my life
every two weeks on Wednesday Wednesday
evening we'd meet at Stanford Linear
Accelerator centers auditorium that was
the most important motivating driving
force not because we were building
technology of the new technology based
on microprocessor chips but because we
had people that were that had come out
of the you know things like anti-war
movement they were speaking about all
these great social changes we were gonna
have the ability to type a message on a
computer and a thousand people could
read it and know where a plan had been
changed and we were going to have
teacher have computers that taught a
child and looked at what they typed back
and by interacting with them was gonna
use a hundred percent of the brain
instead of ten percent and these these
ideas as accurate as they were not just
influenced us as to we were gonna change
life forever
the person who knew how to write a
program was gonna solve the financial
problems of their company better than
the company's huge mainframe computer
right on their own little machine in
front of them they were gonna be able to
solve the problems quicker and they'd be
more important than the CEO of the
company God the way that made us feel
these were incredible motivating factors
and motivation is the most important
thing you got to have inspiration which
gives you an idea of a direction you
want to go in you gotta have motivation
a reason to want to do it and that was
what drove me it was that I was doing
helping with my technical talents I was
helping the the people who were gonna
take this world to a new place by
getting their own computers as a start
and I don't know if that was the whole
question answer I wouldn't just flesh it
out a little bit I mean part of the
question is about we groups like this
are gathering so we we also teach a case
here on on McAfee and John McAfee and
you know and and John ran a bulletin
board out of his house
you know back in the day and then he
would throw pizza parties for for the
people who were bulletin board members
would come over to the house and eat
pizza and talk about the things you were
just talking about
and so the question I guess is is is
where those groups today do they do they
exist where are they how does one find
them in those early days of computers we
had this incredible incredible thing
happening with lots of these groups of
people that had neat little ideas people
that almost had nothing in the world in
terms of money or resources or had
businesses before just setting up little
outlets that we're gonna lead to these
these big huge great things and valuable
companies and everything like that over
and over just thousands of them were
springing up in that time frame doesn't
happen anymore and pretty much it's
difficult to sit down and design a
product out of chips that use
electronics today in those days you
could just buy some chips and and hook
them together and build something now
almost all the designs have to go under
one chip that costs a buck to make and
in the middle of the chip you can't see
if it's a good design or a bad design
there isn't as much motivation to work
at it as an artist and make it really
perfect you know well there is to some
people there's some you can't take it
away but it's so it's not as exciting
that a high schooler could just come up
with an easy idea and make something
great how was where's the creation being
done today hey when people set up their
MySpace pages and they set up their
their little on their network gaming as
they build their communities and all
that I think that's the that's the same
that's where the creative energies are
coming out
you can't slow down the percentage of
the brain that wants to create you know
it's it's in people and it just will
find its paths you spend some some of
your time with robotics clubs in high
schools and I thought do they remind you
of your younger self are they different
in or similar the robotics competitions
that I spend a lot of time with FIRST
Robotics is one of them and we want to
basically get to a point where the
technologist the person knows technology
and math and science is respected like
the athletes and the and you know
celebrities and things like that movie
stars but well you know and we haven't
achieved that yet and I've got some I'm
working on trying to improve that but I
like meeting with the groups of kids
because it's something important in
their life
detective they're finding a lot of them
discover that I want to be an engineer I
want to be a technologist building these
robots human sized robots that play
games and compete is actually kind of
fun and I do see them a little bit like
myself although usually the
got into that category in the schools
aren't the in some case some cases they
are the bright kids like I was in some
cases they're just people just sort of
stumbled into it and can bolt some
screws together but still they're
fighting that's it's my value in the
world you know it's like that movie lady
in the water you know we all got to find
our own place much higher in my own life
that in most people and I just because I
was a quiet person not in the social
groups at school I get a lot of thinking
out philosophies of life you know things
like you shouldn't do what everyone else
is doing only because they're doing it
like drinking at a party you should
decide on your own there's a reason for
drinking and drink alone if you really
believe at least the first time at least
the first time if you believe it and
then you'll make your make your
decisions differently you should not do
anything and that you're afraid to tell
your parents about it's sort of like an
openness and Auntie I won't have my life
be so private I will talk about because
then that'll keep me from I still would
do wrong things and I would tell my
parents what I did like the free-foam
called devices and Steve Jobs and I made
we told our parents when we started
Apple we needed to get the signal into a
television set or it was useless
computer and I wouldn't let Apple build
a transmitter a modulator for like
channel 3 or channel 33 to do that
because I'd been a ham radio operator
and we have to guard the airwaves
against anybody building little
transmitters and there was no law yet as
to how much power you could use and so
we another company had to build that
part of the formula it's just like I
just would put be very strict on a lot
of these things I wouldn't let a PR
person write an article for a magazine
for me I only write my own article I
wasn't going to let somebody change it
just because they were good at marketing
now I realize I was wrong - that was the
right for the best people should do
their parts of their roles in any job
but no I kept very tight here is Who I
am was a little bit strict but I'm gonna
live by it
yeah definitely not religious though
how was it was such a strong set of
values and ethics to work with Steve
Jobs that might not have had the same
values and how did you deal with
compromising
well one things I was taught also was
the further you go in life and in
business and up the ladder and
everything is how the more most
important thing is how well do your
coworkers
like you so I was always gonna be
pleasant like to everybody and never get
into arguments and fights and tell
people OFF
so um I see all sorts of people to get
into huge fights with each other and
this and that even people that do me
wrong and I have this philosophy if they
do you wrong you did them right you know
it's something I think Jesus said but
I'm not sure I never read the Bible but
I've heard things like that but that
goes into my mind and so even when there
was a time when Steve Jobs and I
designed a game for Atari called
breakout and he told me that we got paid
700 bucks and he wrote me a check for
350 twelve years later I read in a book
he got paid thousands you know we were
just best friends with no money and why
I mean if but if he had asked me to I
would have said I'll do it for 25 cents
I didn't care about I didn't care about
the money and if he needed the money
that's fine and so that was sort of an
unethical treatment I can't do the sorts
of things that he does but I can
absolutely be around everybody and
they're all my friends no matter what
and what they do you need and also you
need some people that are a little bit
of sort of the hard guy and you know and
and does some bad things almost and
willing to to run companies business
ethics it's not the same as personal
ethics and in my life I try to make them
more the same in other words if a I was
at a store one time when I was young and
a clerk was saying wow you know these
businessmen go out and they get to write
off their lunch and I thought yeah if a
normal person who has the cost of their
life is driving to work and eating if
they could write off their meals and
their cars they have better meals and
better cars just like businessmen do and
I goes right down to the tax laws that
you know the personal is ethics aren't
treated the same as business and in
business you do whatever's necessary for
your company to make its profit and you
throw out and there are some cases that
are just very much like deception and
lies and trickery and it goes on you
know law I couldn't do that personally
so I decided I'd say at the bottom of
the org chart and never run a company
and it out boy just succeeded I think
have time for one more question
yeah
Microsoft is also trying to do great
things they stumbled into this industry
that was gonna grow to be one of the
hugest things in the world they stumbled
into the right time just just as we did
and we're trying to you know use their
knowledge of technology to build
products that would help people believe
in that there was a big dichotomy was so
pirates of Silicon Valley movie portrays
a lot of it between Apple moving we move
towards the Macintosh the beautiful
human world and they stayed back in the
technical typing lines you know using
your brain power worlds and thinking
those things but we might have made a
mistake too and by jumping into a
technology before it can be priced right
to make a good product for people you
step in early and you make less than
less than the product they should have
and too expensive and too small a screen
and black and white only and you take a
bunch of steps back to try to you know
get a new technology going to early
whereas if you waited five years ten
years all of a sudden that would be just
it fits into everyone's price and
everyone's gonna make it including
Microsoft and so Steve Jobs used to be
very concerned that here was Bill Gates
that he had a chance he could do things
good for the world make up Macintosh for
themselves at twice the cost but instead
well he wasn't making computer seems
just making the operating system but
that he wasn't he wasn't using his
ability to you know take the world in
good direction he was just going after
the quick profits but the quick profits
you know might have been the right way
to you know size of company and things
like that
now one thing is Apple had always had
this philosophy to that we did the
hardware in the software from day one I
did them on their first computers and we
would always do the whole job now we've
got the the sales for your music the
sales for your music we've got the
computer we've got the operating system
we've got the application we've got the
devices and we've got the online
services dot Mac so we can build the
whole package with one click type
operation somebody like Hewlett Packard
wanted to do something great for people
to change their lives on computers it's
always a limited by they're still stuck
with Microsoft on one end of the
solution and it really limits how they
could they can't do the things that
Apple has done and not only that if they
start now they're years behind so I feel
very good about Apple in that sense
that we kept control of things and of
the the entire solution so I've I've
read where you've expressed some
sympathy for the the government's
antitrust actions against Microsoft now
decade ago thinking that labeling them
and monopolies was was it was a
reasonable conclusion for them to come
to do you think they blame the monopoly
everyone agrees on that
yeah abusing it yeah do you think do you
think that that the the the competitive
landscape has changed in a way that
makes their position less less central
less important less problematic
Microsoft is still being watched over
very heavily a good friend of mine is in
charge of monitoring their compliance
with a lot of the Department of Justice
decisions against them but Microsoft
basically by having their monopoly power
could go out and attack other markets
for example if you owned all the gas
stations of the country you would all of
a sudden start a car company and
announce you're changing your nozzles
that'll only fit your cars so the other
car companies go bye-bye that's an abuse
of monopoly power you you were in a
position and Microsoft did that with
their operating systems and other
monopolies that they had and they had
monopolies not because Apple wasn't
there but because people who get stuck
on a computer with certain applications
can't easily switch and funny thing is
by those definitions the first five
pages of the finding of fact in the
legal judgment against Microsoft the
first five pages Apple was a monopoly to
Macintosh bonus they're gonna walk into
store and buy a Macintosh and so Apple
then could put it the music program put
music programs out of business cream and
the photo program put and Apple could
take over all these little side markets
and projects and it sort of slipped
under everybody's radar because we
supposedly had only a few percent of the
world's market and but having a few
percent is good too because it makes you
feel special and every time the market
share went down a little I felt more
special you know and now it's going up
so your dismissal
well you're still pretty special to us
and I want to thank you for being so
open and generous with your time and
and coming in spending this time with us
thank you I hope everyone gets lot out
of it